James is on Twitter Dave can you help me
understand if this new tax bill is going
to help or harm the middle class well
regardless of your politics I can tell
you this think with me just just use
your brain
pull your brain out of your politics for
a second people think with me who better
handles money for the good of society
individuals or the government companies
or the government who is the most
efficient user of money and thereby
better for society individuals of the
government companies or the government
answer is never the government is
society better off the less money
government extracts from it answer yes
so regardless of the technical tactical
breakdowns of whether you personally
will see a 942 dollar change in your tax
bill next year
96% will or whatever these analysis are
you see coming out everywhere it appears
most everybody is going to get a little
bit back a little bit different some
more than others
you know and a lot of people don't even
pay taxes you know that right like 50%
of the people in the United States don't
pay any federal income tax so you need
to keep that in mind yes bizarre if you
think about it yeah if you make a
certain income you get money from the
government you don't give money the
government and unearned income tax
credit you get a you get taxes back and
you're painting in you know more back
than you paid in one of the two you get
money out I mean your net effect is you
get money out you don't put money in for
most
that's half the people listening or half
the people in the world in the US that's
what it is so if you want to call the
portion of those middle-class they're
they're not no change except that the
culture is always better off the
community is always better off the
nation is always better off when it has
less taxes extracted from it now some of
you do not believe that the money will
result in someone doing something with
it in the marketplace that everybody is
just going to let the rats just take
their money and nobody benefits well it
is their money by the way but aside from
that private property issue I'm wealthy
if I have more money do you know what I
do you think I just put it all in the
bank somewhere or hide it under my
mattress I mean what do I do
well I buy stuff with it and when I buy
something with it whoever made that
thing gets paid whoever sells that thing
gets paid whoever owns the store where
that thing is sold gets paid and then
when they get money so if I go across
the street to a restaurant and I spent
money the server gets money the cook
gets money
the restaurant owner gets money the
restaurant manager gets money the
janitor that sweeps up the floor at the
restaurant gets money because I'm a
customer it's more likely to continue
and there's more money going over there
so if they have more money what do they
do
oh they spend it then where do they
spend it I'll doubt the hardware store
if the guy at the hardware store has
more money because I spent money at the
restaurant and then the restaurant
spends money at the hardware store this
is called monetary policy for those of
you that are uninitiated it is called
the flow of money it's probably called
money currency you ever heard that it's
called currency because it flows and has
a current to it it is not a dead end
River and money is not finite there's
not a fixed pie meaning if I get more it
means someone else got less that's
someone money's not like a pie it's more
like candle
Rabbi Levin says if I light your candle
off of my candle now we have two candles
that are lit that's how money works it
doesn't work where if I you know i light
your candle then mine goes out you know
that's not that's not how it works
so all of that to say you know you know
you can call it trickle-down economics
you can scream and flop your liberal
self around on the floor if you want
doesn't work the rich just keep getting
richer wealth inequality well it has
never there's never been a culture in
the history of the world you can find no
historical evidence anywhere that says
that by extracting money from one class
that the other class prospers
it's called socialism economically at
its core and socialism doesn't work
there's a it's a failed experiment
communism the more of a failed
experiment and so if you believe in
communism and socialism then you know
you that's an economic form of
government but it has a bad track record
and so it has to do with equalizing the
inequality of wealth except for the
people who run the place and there's
always the aristocracy that in even in
the liberal mentality they are stocker
zillions are very very rich and so
there's always this wealth inequality
even in a pure communist exciting it's
like everybody's gonna be equal except
for the bunch that put it together you
know so that's really how it works so be
thinking about that so the bottom line
is does the middle class is it going to
help or harm the middle class a new tax
bill well the new tax bill in general
puts more money into the economy and
less money to the government anytime
that happens it's a good day it's that
much less money that they have to poorly
managed was that kind horribly managed
that much less money that they have to
mess with and screw up in about $25,000
hammers and $32,000 toilet seats yeah
you know the stories and you've seen it
too so the last money that we send up
there to be inefficiently you
is better for everyone everyone as a
general macro statement now individually
you know you can dissect the actual law
itself and figure out who's going to get
what tax cut and then you can try to
make some sub positions as to what might
happen with that but you know the
question is does it does the economy
grow more when government extracts money
from the economy and increased taxes or
does the economy grow more when the
government releases money into the
economy instead of extracting it it's
kind of common sense you know it to be
an economic genius to figure this out
and it does work it does work now
government has some things it does but
it doesn't do anything efficiently it
has some things it does that only it can
do but this idea that poor people are
helped by government programs is a joke
really seriously I mean look it's a very
very inefficient the millions of dollars
it takes to get $1 to a poor person is
amazing and and so you know I overall
it's gonna help the middle class it's
gonna help the lower class cuz it's
gonna help society helps upper class too
and by the way that's okay it's okay if
people didn't rob anybody and steal
anything they just did more work and so
more stuff than you did so they've got
more than you got it's how it works Bill
Gates has got more than I got he sold
more stuff than I have he's helped more
people than I have so don't be mad at
Bill Gates even do anything wrong at
least not for becoming wealthy you don't
want to be mad at him he just sold a
bunch of computers like a whole bunch of
them like change the world you know
don't be mad don't be mad any you know
rich people are not evil people they
just serve at a different level there's
a few of them are evil but there's a few
poor people are evil too and a few of
you're too stupid to be believed you got
your head stuck far up your politics you
quit thinking about these things clearly
yeah it's a disease that's out there so
that's the answer
it's kind of a philosophical economic
answer rather than a specific technical
one can you help me understand if this
new tax bill is going to help or harm
the middle class I think I sufficiently
described it it's going to help everyone
lower taxes always does this is the Dave
Ramsey show